you know another big another big topic
in the book was about forgiveness too
and you know i think this is such a
pertinent one because i think the one
that can almost probably bring well me
but maybe maybe anyone listening is just
not only forgiving others but maybe most
importantly yourself because the way you
treat yourself is the way you treat
others so if you can't forgive yourself
how can you really forgive anyone else
and like what haven't we all done so
many things in your in our life where
we're like man i need to forgive myself
for
xyz
abc def like all the different things
that happen and it's like you know maybe
that's something good to talk about is
just yes forgiveness and the role that
it plays and why it's such an important
part of moving forward
so where where our power is and where we
can bring the most love light support
into the planet is right here in this
moment right so what i was saying about
behavior we've all done [ __ ] we've all
done stuff that we wouldn't do again
that we may regret whatever it is but we
cannot take it back
so in the whole chapter there's a
practice and i'll simplify it here but
it's where you list your sun qualities
which are the ones we like to you know
we like to share i'm patient i'm a good
friend
i remember everybody's birthdays like
whatever it is i you know i i'm generous
whatever it is we list it pretty easy to
rattle off right and then we and i
recommend doing this after we meditate
so we have a chance to just be more
rooted and grounded and then we start to
write our lunar qualities which are the
parts of us that we don't necessarily
like to share with the world
but as we we continue to go back to this
practice it goes deeper and deeper so
oh
you know i actually can be judgmental or
i can be mean or it can be exclusive or
it can be snobby or whatever it is and
then we list them and then what happens
when you list those danica is you will
start to feel the reactions of the ego
in terms of sensations in your body your
body will reflect um your reaction so
what does that mean you may start to
feel your heart racing or you may start
to feel for me it feels like
constriction so a constriction in my my
belly or in my heart
so what that means is
we still have attached energy to those
parts of us that we haven't metabolized
or we haven't processed we sort of
pushed away into the shadow right carl
jung talks about bringing things in out
into the light so it actually starts to
melt the darkness just by nature of
starting to see things so in this
practice we want to hold the sun
qualities and the moon qualities up
equally and look at them like like a you
know yin yang like both of these are
part of me and we let the sensations
rise and fall which is helping us to
metabolize the shame and the guilt and
then we realize then the next practice
after that is going beyond that and
realizing the surface all these
behaviors danica it's still the ego like
acting out of its wounds and underneath
that is the stability of the true self
that is beyond behavior now as we get
really anchored in of course our actions
and our words are an extension of our
true self but right now we're you know
we're having a human experience so the
duality is that we're becoming as humans
we're still evolving and becoming and
there's the true self part of us that is
already whole and complete so there's a
little bit of this duality this play so
what it means is we forgive ourselves
for being human we don't trample down on
that humanness we don't beat ourselves
up forever because we can't take it back
we learn the lessons we continue to
evolve and we continue to align more to
the true self
yeah i love that practice of being able
to look at the sun and yes
and look at those qualities and
identifying starting to almost basically
like
give your
familiarize yourself with what it feels
like to be
uh
in love to to have your heart opening to
be
joyful and then to feel what it feels
like in your body because this the body
ends up becoming like the barometer for
things yes and i'm sure that that's
plays a huge role in your life like you
know how does the body feel when a
situation comes up someone something any
anything the body is the indicator it's
not like it's not you don't always get
some there's just a booming voice from
above going like this is a bad decision
i mean you might hear some sort like i
call them like knowings like you know
something just hits you in a couple of
words but a lot of times it's a it's a
body that it's the it's the physical
sensation first but then on the other
side when you can feel the contraction
and then you can start to identify the
more you practice that um back and forth
and knowing what that's like to go out
into the real world and have things
happen and be like oh wow i'm feeling
that this must mean something something
is like i should be cautious right now
um i think is such a valuable practice
for somebody what would they do so
what's the practice then with the you
know the the moon the lunar side of your
your your personality and um
what you do with those is there
something you're supposed to actually do
other than just witness them to
balance them or dissolve them or
or or create some sort of alchemy with
them yeah so that this is the whole
chapter which again is in part one which
is about getting past the biggest blocks
so there's a you know that's similar but
there is a extended practice in the fear
chapter which is actually the first one
um fearlessness which yo bananda says if
we um 26 soul qualities that a human
needs to develop in order to reach their
fullest potential um fearlessness is
number one because if we're riddled with
fear we don't even want to see we don't
even want to get on the path in the
first place so what we want to do is we
want to just start to see and witness in
these practices so we're sort of like
pulling things out of the dark corners
and we're starting to look right so the
word enlightenment again means freedom
we can never be free if we are
controlled by we get hijacked or we act
all these patterns we don't even know
what's going on we just think to
ourselves we project we blame we're like
oh that person's an [ __ ] all right i
just don't like them or whatever it is
it's like always out here versus shining
the mirror inside and seeing oh you know
my true nature is bliss and
unconditional love and what are the
things that have happened that create
distortions and that like why do i act
out in these ways or why does this
really bother me so for me danica oh my
gosh when i started doing this work
i used to think okay i like to move
things along the most um
one of the things that bothered me the
most was when people interrupted me
right
or i would go into this you know
explanation let's say oh phil should
need a lot of dairy and then they
wouldn't agree with me so part of me was
like oh you know
it's just annoying i would just like
toss it off as this person's annoying
but i started to really sit with this
okay so
it gets deeper to answer your question
we build and build we start to see
what's there and then we start to
dissolve it in different ways and
different practices of bringing in more
light because these different these
lunar aspects are you know darkness and
what is darkness darkness is an absence
of light darkness is not necessarily
evil we don't want to create shame and
you know weigh ourselves down it's just
that we need to nourish these aspects of
us so for me i could see oh you get
really impatient when people interrupt
you when they don't agree with you what
is that so then i would sit with it and
through this work through these
practices i could see oh the reason it
bothers me so much is because it's
triggering some very primal um fear in
me that i'm not good enough to be seen
or heard and underneath that was like
i'm not if i'm not good enough to be
seen and hurt it's because i'm not
lovable
right like a deep deep deep primal wound
you know things that happened in my
childhood
and so once i saw that as the root the
behavior was an extension but the root
wound which again we i take you
sequentially into healing this
was this oh i don't feel lovable and
once i saw that danica then i started to
tune into the ways in which we give
ourselves love
no more like dancing around or all the
ways in which i was giving my power away
trying to get the love and reinforce
myself and validate myself which is
really validating the ego anything from
outside instead it was like well i can
show up for myself i can give myself the
love i can again self-soothe validate
and the healing that came from that was
so tremendous because what happens then
danica and this is what this is what
cures a lot of relationship issues is we
then become whole as individuals so when
we're with our partner we're with
someone else a friend we're not trying
to get anything from them right we're
not trying to get them to agree with us
we're not trying to get them to see our
exact perspective we're just sharing
life
and oh my god danica my
my in-laws came last week who are very
intense and they've bothered me a lot in
the past and this is just how much the
work continues i was just there and i
got to tell you honestly from my heart
they didn't bother me at all all the
ways in which they'd like say things and
visited it like my god they don't get it
at all
it's hard to get to that point where you
actually can see it in real life real
time
different
good it adds up stop these practices
dana i'm saying you just like seven
minutes of meditation then you do a
check-in during the day which could be
90 seconds one of my practices or five
minutes and the end of the day you think
oh what's that going to do but really if
you're turning the energy inward which
is always going out and the realizations
may come it's non-linear so you don't
realize how much it starts to add up and
accrue and build into this more
expansive way of looking at things in
this much more
grounded place where we are because
trying to get stuff from people all the
time and you know all the ways in which
we really are trying to get things it's
part of our primal fear attached to our
identity it's an exhausting way to live
life and it's arduous and it actually
blocks abundance it blocks love it
blocks a lot of things from coming in
because this desperate energy is really
an energy of lack and it actually repels
things from us
you said that fear
is actually
you feeling a lit like you're lacking
something right isn't that what you say
that fear is do you think you're missing
something yeah fear is being an ego
because if i'm an ego i'm scared that oh
my god i'm getting older my body's going
to break down all this stuff's going to
happen to me and you know someone's
going to outdo my stuff my project at
work i'm not going to get the promotion
it's because we're still here all the
time it doesn't mean we need to we're
going to take steps we're going to work
on our skills we're going to be in the
world but when we tune into the true
self this eternal part of us we don't
have the same
fears that are taking over life every
day you know one of my other favorite
chapters danica is the warrior chapter
right and this um sanskrit word is uh
costrya this warrior part of us um you
know in yogananda's commentary he says
something throw yourself into the din of
battle and do not worry about results so
this means when we're living from our
heart when we are taking right action
dharma so we've concentrated our energy
and then we see where we want to put it
we go for it we create we're not riddled
with fear of what if this doesn't work
out what if you know they don't like me
and that was also a big difference in
writing this book danica i think you
know as an author and you know this too
the publisher wants to have input like
oh this is what's trending this is
what's going on out here products
whatever it is and so it's almost this
reverse engineering of here's what's out
here and here's how we reflect that
with this it was none of that outside it
was like boom this is inside of me and i
feel like i feel so passionate about
this and so it's it's unfolding from the
inside out like i think this is how our
best stuff is created whoever we happen
to be is we're we're um birthing
something truly it's so connected so
deep within us and then it comes out of
our unique talent and our unique energy
and i think when we over evaluate again
the ego just trying to figure out from
here and then do it the other way
that's when you know things don't always
work out so well
what are some practices that you've
noticed over time
that help get you into that state of
more of a clear channel more
present more connected to the true self
and the message that you have and then
what have you noticed over time or some
of the things that you do that take you
out of that or make it feel a lot maybe
more blurry and a little less clear and
a little less a little less um
obvious what you're what you should be
doing next or saying next or even yes
yeah just doing sometimes is even the
way it's like i don't know what should i
do now so i keep i keep saying this word
danica practices because i think that's
the most important thing here right it's
like otherwise we're just a leaf blowing
in the wind like once in a while i do a
yoga retreat and i feel good or i see a
happy instagram post and i'm like yeah
but
practices that really are what is how we
are working with energy so for instance
in the morning routine i teach hot water
with lemon great good for your digestion
get the vitamin c in get the hot water
in which helps you feel stabilized in
your physical body take your spo
probiotics do something for your gut
health and then always always it's
sitting to meditate even if it's seven
minutes in the practical enlightenment
meditations that i teach because from
the beginning of the day we want to be
creating a pattern of flow of our energy
where we're not just tuned out here but
we have this um inner connection that
we're starting the day with and so it
may feel restless at first it was
excruciatingly
difficult for me to sit in meditation
when i started you know over 12 years
ago
but now that i have been meditating for
a while it continues to get deeper um
and deeper and deeper so anyone that's
like well you know what's the best thing
to do to get started i say you know do
the meditation every morning um if you
don't have seven minutes i mean i'm
sorry but you gotta adjust your life
right